enthüllt einfach ab hier kommt das kind
kriegt die leute was geht ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut ich habe etwas
krasses gemacht und zwar habe ich einen
500 euro restposten paket von aldi lidl
und netto glaube ich also ein discounter
paket bestellt das ist heute angekommen
diese palette habe ich bestellt und zwar
eine restposten lcd tvs digitalkamera
mediaplayer mix palette elektronische
geräte haushalt elektro in der
beschreibung steht auch nochmal kann
alles drin sein bis zum kochtopf über
den fernseher was auch immer ich habe
mir eine palette gekauft dann wird es
ein bisschen teurer 325 euro plus 89
euro versandt plus mehrwertsteuer
beladen bei 492 euro
schon hatten aber die checks mal ab ob
sich das gelohnt der lieferant meinte
die liegt 240 kilo ich glaube so schwer
war es nicht seht selbst dann hat man
das aus und ich hoffe das wird cool die
ganzen sachen werden auch auf meinem
shop dann nachher angeboten also wenn
irgendwas interessiert seid kein kleiner
ob sie das nicht tun wird aber es wird
trotzdem lustig letzte ach du scheiße
das ding ist viel zu groß dachte dass
wir viel kleiner
das sich 100 kilo wie soll ich das denn
wie soll ich das denn hier hoch kriegen
muss es jetzt ein und auspacken und dann
hoch hochschleppen also damit habe ich
jetzt wirklich nicht gerechnet dieser
paket wurde kommt an und sagt mir ja das
mit 244 so was das ist alles drin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja ich eine böse was ist da denn drin
also gut das ist jetzt schon brauchbar
haben jetzt noch dabei täglich kann ich
ja schauen einen staubsauger drin das
war eine natur die hand nimmt ist
eigentlich weiß man leute was mache ich
dann nur solche wir befinden uns jetzt
hier bei mir in meinem neuen büro
sozusagen das hat mich heute morgen so
schockiert als diese fette laden dann
kam ich habe deshalb viel kleiner volk
stellt der boote meint erst das wiegt 2
144 kilo es waren also 120 würde ich
sagen dann muss ich alles einzeln
auspacken und hier aufräumen
die schon relativ viel voll ja mit
einigen sachen davon kann ich was
anfangen mit den anderen erregern ist
habe ich überhaupt haben und hier da ist
halt nochmal ultra viel schrott drin
auch brauchbare sachen vielleicht die
haben ja einfach keine ahnung das machen
wir gleich jetzt als letztes würde ich
mal sagen ja das ist ja schon gesehen
dass hier sind jetzt er die sachen die
man dann wirklich direkt oder die
einwirkung ins auge geschossen sind ich
habe jetzt zum beispiel vier mal diesen
dampf drin der hat im internet glaube
ich 59 euro soll gekostet deswegen keine
ahnung ob in berlin so viel 950 euro
kauft ist halt die frage also ich kann
schon verstehen wie solche sachen da
drüber
den haben wir vier oder fünf mal also
hier 12 und dann hier noch 34
und da noch ein paar sachen also
schon verrückt was ich aber unbedingt
mal kurz erwähnen muss ich werde alle
sachen zum verkauf anbieten das heißt
wenn ihr irgendwas davon gebrauchen
könnt ist in restposten zu einem guten
preis auf meinem neuen eigenen shop
lucky dog ii.de ist doch in der video
bestellung verlinkt deswegen steht jetzt
gerade auf werbung check das super gerne
ab da könnt ihr das denn einkaufen
versandzeit zwei bis drei werktage falls
sich irgendwas davon interessiert okay
leute erst mal bisschen gewartet das
sind auch noch sagen da drin war absolut
genial habe ich mir schon immer
gewünscht mega drive produkt und zwar
haben wir hier eine kita max massage
matte mit vibrationen und während also
ich weiß nicht wer das braucht und ich
sehe mich da ich auch gut drin so hier
so entspannt mit so einer matte habe ich
auch mal googeln wird sogar schätzen wie
tot und ich würd sagen so 40 50 euro
jetzt sich euro bei mir gibt's was haben
wir für 27 oder so beim versand ist
natürlich bei mir auch immer inklusive
und ich werde auch kein minusgeschäft
mache viermal hat das ganze dann habe
ich hier noch gefunden den boom max obst
und gemüse schneider kein plan wie das
klingt funktioniert ich brauche doch
nicht deswegen fall komme ich das
natürlich auch hier weil ich nicht dass
das lag irgendwie gerade darum kein fan
was das sein soll sieht aus wie eine kur
oder anzug das ist ein hemd oder neu im
trend ich weiß was das ist das ist dafür
das kommt drauf und dann wird das
automatisch durch die warme luft
gebügelt es kommt darauf und ich hab den
händlern auch immer leute so sieht das
aus ich will das jetzt gar nicht
herausnehmen weil das wäre ja dumm sonst
ist ja nicht mehr original verpackt aber
das hemd muss ich jetzt leider wieder
hier zu stopfen
das ist ein bisschen heiß jetzt haben
wir noch zwei motive liegen da stehen
halt kommt im 2 jetzt bin ich gespannt
weil diese pakete entscheiden ob sich
der kauf gelohnt hat oder ob es ein flop
5 500 euro
je nachdem was jetzt hier drin der
werden auf jeden fall glaube ich noch
mal kartons drin sein hat auf jeden fall
jemand haustieren ich glaube dass sich
für vögel oder kaninchen oder und auf
jeden fall aus wie ein hamsterrad daran
woher soll ich denn jetzt wissen es ist
wie soll ich das denn jetzt verkaufen
wenn ich nicht mehr weiß was das ist
nein dass er nicht hamster für hamster
ich glaub schon was kostet denn so
einfach kommt da kind aber ich glaube
schon dass die teuer sind ein paar
ausgegeben ja das sind auf jeden fall
noch drei hamsterkäfig oder hier ist
jetzt so wichtig wie kaninchen ist für
irgendwas anderes für frösche
jetzt haben wir hier noch ein dass so
viele kaninchen sonst alten garten oder
weiß nicht in welche vogelkäfig ja das
gehört natürlich dazu
oder weil da hat er bisher keinen käfig
bei schreibwaren die kommentare was es
ist oder ich verrückt dass bis dahin
food verordnung aber so ein vogelkäfig
kann man sowas zu nehmen ja also leute
wenn ihr ein kanarienvogel zu hause habe
und ein neues zuhause braucht kauft euch
dass das war es von den großen sachen
wir haben jetzt hier noch jede menge
kleine zeug drin abschluss überfordert
guck mal wie viel das ist ich kann
wirklich überhaupt nicht einschätzen ob
sich das am ende für mich lohnt wird
oder nicht aber wir schauen erst haben
wir noch drin
glas und wasserkocher keine ahnung kann
man bis auf 10 15 euro
was richtig ich muss das machen dann
haben wir hier ein der selbst gießen der
blumen top so ist nämlich schon öfter
mal gehört ja auch nicht schlecht von
lacie wie wenn man mal auf reisen ist
oder so was mir aufgefallen ist hier ist
ultra viel zug drin von die höhle der
löwen kennt man ja ne dieses format
haben wieder etwas neues auf den markt
geschmissen wird im endeffekt erst mal
hört sich geil an kauften aber trotzdem
niemand und das landet dann vielleicht
in diesen paketen ich habe ein abdruck
das hier ist maler schutz für ihr auto
und das wird tatsächlich im internet für
das muss ich noch mal nach und es war
auf jeden fall teuer also hier werden
zwei dosen co marco mader schutz für ihr
auto für 50 euro verkauft aber das ist
schon irgendwie bisschen teuer oder
wobei hier ist jetzt nun auch nur eine
dose drin also 25 euro finde ich auch zu
teuer wenn die irgendwie für zehn euro
kaufen wäre das ja schon in ordnung also
ich denke ich werde die für zehn euro
plus 300 für 13 euro vielleicht sondern
von anbieten
wir haben wir noch eine fahne und wie
viele marathons sind ja ich habe da eine
pflanze selbst bewässern der pflanze
geführt und dann haben wir noch sehr oft
so von allein schon dieser name gentle
monkeys nass tücher aus liebe zum
fahrzeug irgendwas fürs fahrzeug das
kostet der mit 115 euro absolut keinen
plan was es ist falls ihr das gebrauchen
könnt ich kann so überhaupt nicht
einschätzen ob sich das am ende für mich
halbwegs lohn ob topleute überhaupt
sowas kaufen oder ich weiß es nicht
was wir auch ein super oft drin haben
ist ebenfalls man die höhle der löwen
kinderschutz sagt fürs auto wenn er sagt
ich soll mit einem anderen paar hat
diese ganzen würde der löwen sachen
testen könnt ihr super wenn man nach
oben da lassen auf jeden fall ist es so
dass das kind sich im auto nicht
bekleckert die idee finde ich gar nicht
so schlecht aber ich werde kauften so
was für sein kind maxime miasto da kann
hier so links punkt auf
jobs ließ +12 theilig eine mini
videokamera ein etwa fürs auto security
cam des cam wie auch immer von easy max
also ich glaube die meisten sachen sind
tatsächlich von der druck weil
eigentlich dachte ich das ist nur von
aldi und lidl
ich habe keine übersichten keine ahnung
guck mal 29 eur 23 traum bh mit
reißverschluss 65 stück 55 bhs warum
auch nicht
was so eine größe wahrscheinlich wurden
die deswegen nicht verkauft größe l
gibt's nicht so aber hey ich glaub dass
sich schlafen zu legen ist das glaube
ich
mit m und l und so angegeben also bei
aldi gibt es keine ahnung
auch wieder junge was produzieren die
bei die hürde der linken-spitze dusch
brocken ticker verkauft dass das ist das
richtige frühesten auf titelblättern ja
nicht mal daran dass ich genauso ja da
überhaupt noch was drin ist
die multifunktionale smartphone heizung
aber sowas kostet doch längst guck mal
wie das da drin noch aussieht ob man
hier haben wir noch ein fitness an
aber das werde ich ja nicht einzeln
verkaufen leute wenn ihr irgendwas
glaube ich schon bestellt sei es jetzt
auch eigene sachen die ich dort anbieten
ich werde immer jedes paket man noch so
krims krams meisten ich halt sonst nicht
als eigenes produkt verkaufen kann
deswegen auch diese seien keine ahnung
ob das eben wir haben will
leute ich muss mir noch mal kurz melden
ich freue mich ich habe jetzt alles noch
mal bisschen inspiziert und so das
format die höhle der löwen ist ja an
sich ganz unterhaltsam aber wie kann man
so viel schrott produzieren nicht immer
das was da liegt das ist alles von die
höhle der löwen einfach wer kauft denn
so ein scheiß und dann beschweren sich
leute über den klimawandel
wenn soviel produziert und wenn bei mir
im paket in 15 von diesen sachen landen
da will ich gar nicht wissen wie viel
davon noch existiert na ja trotzdem war
es interessantes zu bestellen wir können
super gerne in die kommentare schreiben
ob ich das öfter machen soll was für
restposten noch besteht oder es gibt
sehr sehr viel und danke fürs zuschauen
daumen nach oben jackson in stockach und
das war von mir
3 wir sehen uns in ein paar tagen wieder